make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay uh so the the second video that we
did
on uh on invincible actually did pretty
well or relatively well relatively
speaking right like i usually use 100
000 views as a litmus test to or really
is kind of like a benchmark
to determine whether or not a video
performs well right if like if it breaks
100
000 views we do it again right if it
doesn't well we maybe try a different
version of it or we just kind of drop it
right
it sort of depends i know it's a high
number but if you're a youtuber that's
how you grow your channel
would you guys believe me if i told you
that with this video it'll be the end of
season one in the tv show right
like that it's it happens so fast right
that's one of the crazy things like the
the tv show was what something like
eight or nine episodes in the first
season and like we're already caught up
12 or 13 issues in and like you're
caught up with the end of the show right
it's it's kind of crazy but one of the
things that happens here is you pick up
with mark during his birthday right like
all his friends are out kind of you know
they're like hey man it was a cool party
and all that kind of stuff and they
basically leave and mark sits down and
watches movies with his dad now the
reality is that debbie
absolutely loves this right and the
reason why is because it's one of the
first
real instances or at least one of those
kind of reminders of normalcy right one
of the things to kind of keep in mind
when you're looking at this from
debbie's perspective
is that she's dealing with a husband who
is by all standards of measurement what
would equate to like a superman-esque
character and a son
who's almost as strong as his father is
right so literally it's just superhero
antics all the time right they're always
here and there and they're always off
and they're always doing things and so
on and so forth and so the notion of
having like a normal family
has is long gone right that was gone
before they even had their family in the
first place right as soon as she started
banging omni man and they popped out a
kid like that normalcy went right out
the window right and so because of that
to kind of see this small little moment
where like a father and son
are watching uh watching day of the dead
it's kind of cool i will say this i said
the same thing on patreon i think day of
the dead is overrated
night of the living dead honestly i
think the 1990s version of night of the
living dead with tony todd is much
better
than like the the day of the dead or
even like the original night of the
living dead but
but nonetheless one of other things that
comes out of this is that because the
guardians of the globe were destroyed by
uh by omni man that you have cecil who
meets with robot and basically says we
need you to form a new team now
one of the big things that goes on here
and this is one of the most important
things that i think you got a glimpse of
in the tv show and i would like to have
seen them do a little more justice with
this is nolan trying to figure out how
to talk to his son right
one of the things that was so great
about the comic the way that kirkman did
it is in so many ways
it humanized nolan right that like nolan
as he's presented in the
show is almost this guy who's just
disconnected from morality and the idea
like he's a guy who's like a sociopath
and like the things he does where he
looks like he's being a good dad or he
looks like he's being
being a good husband because we know his
true nature now that it looks like he
was just
going through the motions and in some
ways he was right like he's pretending
to be a good person
so that he can fit in quote unquote with
society the way a sociopath would
actually do
but the reality is in the comics and one
of the things again i feel like they
only touched on in the show as he's
trying to figure out how to tell a son
the truth and he's genuinely struggling
with it right he's genuinely just
not really sure how to do it you know
again it's it's it's only for a moment
and so i guess maybe it was around the
same time
spent but it's one of those things that
kind of becomes recurring
over the course of the show right one of
those things that you see a few times
here and there now
one of the other funny moments that goes
on here is that you do have
adam eve who's digging mark right like
she's kind of like i mean
here's here's the thing man right like
she's about mark
right i mean we all kind of know well
you know she's kind of like hey you know
like i'm gonna do the girl thing and
play hard to get right which is which is
kind of a hassle but like you know she's
like i'm gonna do that that stuff where
i'm not gonna make it easy for you so on
and so forth i'm not gonna tell you what
i'm thinking right i'm just gonna hope
you get it right when you assume like
that's that's it's one of those weird
things
but when you have this kind of shared
moment between the two of them where
they destroy like this crazy lizard
group which is kind of funny but when
you have this shared moment where
they're kind of talking about superhero
escapades and how they work well
together as a team
robot comes by and it's like hey guys
i'm doing auditions for the new
guardians of the globe uh
mark i'd love it if he did it and he was
like yeah man i'll be right there and
he's like adam eve what do you think
right and then she just gets pissed and
flies off right now the whole reason why
that happened
is because she was kind of enjoying the
moment right and instead of saying
actually i think it'd be kind of cool if
we stayed here and talked some more
instead she just kind of
runs off in a huff right with nobody
knowing why she's upset so it's one of
those
those funny things now the funny thing
about the tv show is they went a lot
more in depth
into the audition ceremony than kirkman
did in the comics now again
i think a lot of this is kind of
kirkman's philosophy coming out of the
walking dead that if you guys ever saw
any of the interviews that he did when
he was talking about the tv show
versus the walking dead comics is he
wanted the show to fix a lot of the
things
or to expand on a lot of the things that
he didn't really like or didn't really
care for the way he originally did it in
the comics
and that kind of seems to be the theme
here right the auditions don't really
happen
you don't really see much going on there
the only thing you really see is rex
and monster girl get into a fight with
each other when he starts mouthing off
and she helps him to understand his
place in the bigger picture which is
exactly what he needed because rex is a
dick
but like like when you only really get
is that right that's the only thing you
really get mark steps in and like
pummels monster girl because
seemingly she's losing control and she's
gonna she's gonna kill rex and
that's it right that's literally all you
get right now one of the things that
kind of goes on
is mark is given the offer to join the
team if he wants to but this is kind of
an important aspect of mark's character
is he turns it down one of the big
differences between mark
and and nolan is that nolan took on the
role of becoming the world superhero
because it was the easiest way to gain
the trust of humanity right to make it
easier and more malleable for him to
basically
invade the world right to actually
conquer the world or at least to set the
stage for the viltromites to invade the
world and conquer it that's one of the
reasons why
he kind of took that role unto himself i
imagine there also might be a little bit
of narcissism
involved in there but for mark he's a
far more humble person
than his father is right partially
seemingly because of his upbringing but
also
because of the people that he spends
time with and the friends that he has
and so that's why he kind of prioritizes
everything else that he has going on
over the notion of like
being a superhero and part of the
guardians of the globe so ultimately you
end up getting duplicate shrinking ray
monster girl black samson and rexplode
as the official roster of the team with
mark kind of having an open slot to join
up whenever he's ready now
one of the other things that kind of
happens here and this is kind of a an
important moment that'll become
significant much much
much later on in the comics is when adam
eve shows up
and then sees mark kissing amber right
it's not a super significant moment it's
a relatively small moment but it's kind
of important nonetheless right and so
what you end up doing here
is basically transitioning to
essentially the arrival of the immortal
now the immortal had basically
been brought back by the mauler twins of
course the idea was that he'd been dug
up by a couple of kids and then the
mauler twins essentially stepped in with
the purpose of bringing the immortal
back and that's kind of the nature of
his character
that so long as the immortal's head is
reattached to his body that he can be
reanimated right he can come back
we don't really know much about his
history beyond that we don't know the
exact way in which he gained his powers
we simply just know that he has them but
it is kind of an
important little tidbit here because
what you end up having is the immortal
kind of initially the mahler twins
looking to use the immortal for their
own ends and planting like a mind
control device it doesn't work right
immortal wakes up
seemingly you know as far as he's
concerned the moment that he died right
so kind of
basically experiencing this rush of
memories and watching all the other
guardians die
only to find out in these final moments
that it was no one who did it and then
dying himself and then immediately goes
after nolan right now
this is incredibly important here
because the fight that takes place
between the two
is one where you could easily
misconstrue it and see as it being
something that's evenly matched
and to a degree it is but one of the
reasons why it looks like it's evenly
matched is because it's nolan trying to
figure out what's going on
if nolan's desire was to kill the
immortal he'd be dead right we saw him
do it before we saw him kill him in an
instant and it wasn't one of those
things where he caught him off guard i
mean i guess at the time that he did but
what'll happen here in a minute we'll
basically lay that to rest and the sense
of the immortal is exceedingly pissed
off now understand
it's not just rage here it's hurt right
it's betrayal
it's the feeling that like he had this
guy who he thought was a friend
that turned against him and then killed
him along with the rest of his allies
the problem with this is that once the
immortal is killed by nolan that mark
is right there right mark sees the whole
thing happen when he's kind of hearing
about his father being caught in a fight
and that's when his dad's like
we need to talk right we need to have a
conversation here and that's the
important thing is because what you get
is this full-on origin of the
viltromites right or at least
most of the origin of the vulture might
now most of this you guys already know
just from watching the tv show right
that the vulture might themselves
essentially turn into like a planet
conquering race
and so it wasn't one of these things
where they would go to a planet
wholesale slaughter it and then they
would call it concord
instead they would go there and then
they would basically expand their empire
and they would give people a choice
right either you serve us or we will
destroy you those individuals who
rebelled and who refused to bend the
knee to the viltrumites were eradicated
right they were wiped out those
individuals who chose to bend the knee
would be brought into the viltrum
empire right and so ultimately what you
ended up having is nolan who ended up
becoming a part of the group that would
actually go out and
conquer these various worlds right now a
lot of this was based was was really
predicated on
the lifespan of the viltrumite race
right because they lived for so
incredibly long
why not use that lifespan to start
conquering worlds right in a more
efficient way to infiltrate those worlds
as opposed to like
sending the entirety of the vulture
might race into a world and then forcing
that world to bend the knee or
eradicating everybody who doesn't then
why not just go there and
infiltrate those worlds now it also made
a lot more sense because there aren't
that many viltrumites left and so why
put all your eggs in one basket right
diversify your stocks
that's basically what this was it was in
a lot of ways them hedging their bets
that if they sent a vulture mite to a
world and the the superhero population
on that world was of such a degree to
where they either fought the villager
might off or they even killed them
then it would give the other vulture
mites a a better understanding
of what that world's capable of and to
be able to plan accordingly maybe it
meant
sending sending the entirety of the
filter might race there whatever the
case happens to be now one thing that i
do also want to specify here that this
is only a part of the origin of the
vulture might race there's a lot more
that goes on here
right there's a lot more that takes
place here but essentially the entire
origin story that nolan
is spilling out to his son is one of
deception and subterfuge
one of espionage trickery manipulation
that he's basically saying i'm a villain
i was sent here as a bad guy and i was
supposed to basically lead the way for
your world
to be conquered but then ultimately i
saved your mom and uh and because your
mom was pretty hot you know i ended up
basically
you know getting with her right you know
we we banged a bunch of times and then
you came out right so like that's
and then over time other superheroes
began to manifest for any number of
reasons and they ultimately ended up
forming the guardians of the globe but
regardless of how
it was sliced no matter how this origin
is told here the entire thing was
predicated on the idea on the notion
that nolan was sent to infiltrate the
world and to basically set the stage for
it to be conquered but something changed
right things switched and what ended up
switching here
is nolan fell in love and nolan began to
realize that you know what it means to
have
a meaningful life i mean up to this
point he was a hammer right so
everything was a nail but then suddenly
he was kind of woken up to this idea
that there's something bigger out there
than just arbitrarily conquering various
worlds in the name of some
empire and not giving it any real
credible thought by having a child by
having a wife having a family he found
a greater meaning in his life he found
value in his life and that's one of the
things that he kind of hit on is that
even when he was serving as part of the
vulture might race he always kind of
felt like something was missing
something was off there was a kind of
hole in him that he couldn't quite fill
but despite what he's gained and despite
the life that he has now and the love
that he feels for his wife and the love
that he feels for his son
at the end of the day he still holds
true to his filter my convictions
and the one thing that really keeps him
separated from being able to truly
connect
with us with his wife and turn code
against the viltrumide empire in favor
of his family
is his longevity that because of how old
he is and because of how long his life
will be
at the end of the day no relationship
that he believes he has
will ever truly be meaningful because in
the end he will always outlive
everything now if i'm a betting man here
i think this is just a defense mechanism
right and it's one of the things that i
think will prove to be true
as you get further and further into the
story that in this bit of a thing here
his whole stance is like well i mean i'm
going to outlive everybody
mark so there's no point having any kind
of a meaningful relationship but that's
the nature of life right i mean in his
in his situation it is for the most part
guaranteed but the fact that we don't
really know what the future holds
is what makes the relationships that we
have so significant you and a friend
could be walking across the street
tomorrow and they get hit by a bus and
die
and the only thing that's going to be
able to kind of get you through that
pain and that anguish
are the times you shared and what nolan
is basically doing is
cutting himself off to all of that right
he's cutting himself off
to all that valuable human interaction
so when the time comes when he does
outlive debbie and debbie dies of old
age that he won't really allow himself
to relish in those beautiful moments
that they had
instead it'll be and this is why i never
have any real meaningful relationships
right it's approaching it from a place
of negativity
it's focusing on the loss instead of
focusing on the game and that's what
makes nolan
it really puts him in this mindset and
that's why when he tells mark
instead of saying you're my son i love
you and therefore to hell with the
vulture might race
right you and i will stand against them
when the time comes that they arrive on
this world
instead he says now i need you to stand
along with me i destroy the guardians of
the globe to weaken the earth's defenses
and so now i need you to join me and to
prepare this world for
conquering at the hands of the
viltrumite race what follows is mark of
course standing up to his father and
basically saying
no right i don't want to have anything
to do with that and and for mark it's a
massive betrayal right because this this
comes from a variety of places right
under normal circumstances you and i
and anybody out here in the real world
assuming that we have a positive
relationship with our fathers
we look up to them right we look to our
fathers as kind of the standard
on what a man should be and in a lot of
ways they're the guiding force on how we
operate as
men through the world we've talked about
that in a multitude of different videos
right that we're born into the world
that we are taught by our parents the
moral compass that they
that they use to see the world and then
eventually we graduate out into the
greater tribe and the moral compass they
gave us
comes into conflict with the moral
compasses of the people around
us and that in turn we adopt and we take
on different moral viewpoints of other
people and combine it with our own it's
what keeps us from being stagnant right
it's what keeps us or allows us to grow
as human beings to grow beyond what our
parents originally taught
us for mark his experiences over the
course of his life have taught him his
father is an
admirable man that his father is a great
man his father
is a champion of the world his father is
a great man even just
on a personal level and now he's being
confronted with the fact that secretly
all of it is a lie
right his father's a terrible person his
father's a villain he was sent here for
the
you know to conquer the world and now he
wants his son to conquer the world too
that he's telling him
none of his relationships matter that
none of nolan's relationships with his
with his friends with his allies even
with his own wife
none of them are relevant that that is
that debbie's some kind of a pet right
she's just a thing that's there and a
time will come when she will die and no
one will not really care all that much
because again he focuses on the loss
instead of on the game
mark refuses to accept that right that
in the end he sees himself as a human he
sees himself as a champion a true
champion of the people
and ultimately in the end he says like
this is my world right this is my home
these are my friends
and i'm not going to let you destroy any
of it and ultimately mark gets into a
conflict with his father now here's the
thing
what follows is probably one of the most
spectacular ass whippings in the history
of comic books and i don't think that
the tv show did it justice
it really really really did it was
amazing because literally
like his father sends him humbling into
the building this entire building
collapses and all the people inside of
it die
and he's like this is like like do you
not understand now this is not your
world right
one punch from from one of our people
and thousands of people
lose their lives it's one of these
things where it's kind of like we are on
a much higher level of power than they
are right
if anything it's pride and it's hubris
just because you've achieved a certain
station in life does not mean that
you're better than those individuals who
are
below your station in life at the end of
the day you still put your pants on the
same way you still need water you still
need food i guess the nolan's case is a
little bit different here and again
it's kind of reaffirming this betrayal
in the eyes of mark how could you on one
hand
claim to be a champion of the people and
then on the other hand seek to stab them
in the back
right like you're shaking your hand
shaking their hand with your right hand
and then stabbing him in the back with
your left right like that's a terrible
thing
more so than that in a lot of ways it
does kind of flip the traditional
superhero mythos on its head
in an interesting way right because if
you were to take this principle that one
punch could destroy thousands of people
that applies to superman the dam between
superman and nolan is a superman chose
to be a good guy nolan chose to be a bad
guy but what happens when a person with
that level of power
uses it for nefarious purposes and
that's what you get here the power of
nolan and mark even with mark being as
young and as weak as he is
and his strength of course will increase
over time even being in that
in that state he's powerful enough to
level cities and there's really nothing
anybody can do here to stop him and
that's what's kind of nuts about this
is because one of the things to notice
here is the fight between mark and the
fight between nolan is a lot more drawn
out here in the comic than it is in the
show
and the show it's it's a huge conflict
right and you've got debbie watching
everything unfold when she was taken to
uh taking to a command center by cecil
hearing everything it is that that
nolan's saying and all that kind of
stuff but the fight's pretty intense
right mark
is just getting wrecked now one of the
big differences here and this is this is
a huge thing to focus on here is a huge
thing to understand
despite all the experience mark has in
being a superhero
he is still woefully unprepared and the
reason why is because
nolan if you notice is not really
fighting with emotion
he's not fighting out of anger he's not
fighting out of wrath
mark is his emotions are getting the
better of him and when you fight in an
emotional state you're almost guaranteed
to lose
unless you're just that much better than
your opponent but mark is not
mark is not that much better than
omniman instead he's getting absolutely
decimated because he's letting his
emotions get the better of him and so
again like that's when nolan even
himself
starts to become emotional screaming at
his son like why do you resist right
like why do you fight on behalf of these
people
whose lives don't matter right like
these people's lives will be a
blink of an eye in comparison to your
life most of these people that you know
you will not even know that they were
alive in the first place you will for
have forgotten about them
like there'll be some name on the tip of
your tongue that you can vaguely
remember
in 200 years right like there'll be
there'll be a thought that might creep
up in the back of your head
and dismissed just as quickly in 300
years right
no one in 500 years no one here is gonna
have any significance to you
so why do you stay here and fight what
are you fighting for
why does any of this matter to you and
at the end of the day when he says like
what are you going to have after 500
years mark's response is
you i would still have you when it's all
said and done
i would still have you dad and
ultimately because of the emotional toll
because of everything that's gone on
here and because
of the fact that mark was just kind of
so open with his with nolan
and really treats him as a dad it opens
nolan up in a way
that he hasn't really experienced before
right it makes him feel vulnerable in a
way that he hasn't really experienced so
ultimately
nolan bales now the big question
everybody has to ask here which of
course is
this is the end of the of basically
season one what happens to nolan
where does nolan go where does where
does all this end up taking off to
like how does all this come together
well we will find out at a future point
in time with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
you